I'm leaving for a while.
Miss 2059 season 2 starts with recordings in July
Of course I play in it.
And this season I am the director. So unfortunately I have to take a step back from YouTube.
But, if you miss me, don't worry!
You can now go to Netflix and watch the You Get Me trailer.
Bella Thorne, Huston Sage and myself play in it!
It is a kind of fun, modern 'Fatal Attraction'.
And if that isn't enough 'Anna' for you, I'll also play 'Stitchers' in the show.
Which can be seen on FreeForm, every Monday at 9pm.
I'm Amanda Weston. Medical researcher, Rockabilly, DJ, lesbian.
Pretty chill girl.
If that's not enough for you, and you think, "OMG, I just need to see more of you!"
I have this book that I have released. It is available on Amazon and everywhere where books are sold.
And ... If that's still not enough for you:
Sorry, I don't have any other things.
Bye!